avec t'avais qu'à michel fize sociologue
bonsoir michel fize merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors comment
interpréter les annonces de jean castex
est ce que le gouvernement at il eu peur
des syndicats mais je crois qu'il faut
d'abord souligner qu'il n'y a pas de
changement de méthode il y à un
changement de style la communication
d'edouard philippe était une
communication directe
j'ai envie de dire juppé yens la
communication de monsieur castex et une
communication beaucoup plus en rondeur
une communication qui prend en compte la
réalité des partenaires des partenaires
sociaux mais ce sont les mêmes mots qui
sont utilisés dialogue concertation
donc là réformes ou les réformes sont
étalés dans le temps parce que on ne
réforme pas en période de crise on
réforme dans une période sociale
tranquille et nous sommes évidemment
nous ne sommes pas dans ce cas de figure
est ce que c'est reculer pour mieux
sauter de la part du gouvernement
finalement savez bon dès lors que l'on
parle de 2021
on est à la veille de l'année de
l'élection présidentielle donc il est
évident que le recul n'est pas loin de
renoncer de fait un renoncement au bois
mal comment cette réforme qui
soulèveraient les mêmes difficultés les
mêmes contestation de la part des
partenaires sociaux parce qu'encore une
fois le projet de fond reste le même à
un projet de retraite universel par
points qui est rejetée depuis le départ
par les partenaires sociaux
donc comme il n'y a pas de changement de
position on peut penser que les
partenaires sociaux remonteront au
créneau pour faire échouer ce projet de
réforme
on a une certaine impression du premier
ministre qui veut jouer la montre en
donnant satisfaction aux syndicats avant
une rentrée qui s'annonce délicate une
rentrée sociale qui
annonce délicate comment vous voyez
d'ailleurs cette rentrée savez la
politique c'est traiter les urgences et
l'urgence aujourd'hui elle est double
triple même elle et sanitaires l es
économique et social donc il y à déjà
pour l'exécutif fort à faire pour
résoudre cette triple crise dont il est
évident que les réformes dès lors qu'il
s'agit de réformes de structure qui
engage une longue durée ne peuvent pas
correctement s'organiser dans ces temps
d'extrême d'extrême difficulté
donc on peut raisonnablement penser que
le projet des retraites
eh bien ce sera pour le prochain
président de la république qui sera
peut-être le même d'ailleurs et d'une
certaine manière est ce que la gronde
sociale elle de son côté ne va pas se
calmer même est ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle va grossir cette vente social au
fur et à mesure du temps vous savez là
nous entrons dans la période des congés
en tout cas de l'arrêt d'une partie de
l'activité économique
donc le vrai test se fera en septembre
mais il est évident que nous l'avons vu
il ya quelques jours avec de nouveaux la
descente dans la rue d'égée les jaunes
et du personnel soignant
on peut penser que toutes sortes de
catégories pour lesquelles les problèmes
n'ont pas été résolus l'un je pense les
avocats qui sont dans une paupérisation
croissante les enseignants qui n'ont pas
obtenu satisfaction par rapport à leurs
revendications et à la reconnaissance de
leur métier tout tous ces problèmes sont
en l'état je le disais d'ailleurs ici
même il ya quelques jours les problèmes
demeurent
ils sont sur la table ils ne sont pas
résolues et compte tenu de la
détermination des catégories en crise à
se faire entendre
on peut évidemment légitimement penser
qu'il y aura de nouveau des mouvements à
la rentrée de septembre
on la répare rapidement évoqué tout à
l'heure et dernière question rapidement
le
premier ministre a dit au patronat et
aux syndicats ce qu'ils voulaient
entendre
l'ère du dialogue à tous les étages
c'est donc ça la méthode castex a
observé la méthode politique c'est une
méthode de communication avant tout donc
on ne sait plus très bien ce qui est
véritablement projet et ce qui est
simplement exercice de style oratoire
c'est un peu dommage que nos démocraties
soit sous le joug effectivement des mots
et non pas des actes
merci beaucoup michel fize rappelle que
vous êtes est sociologue